hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast Dana just checking in on you
just check it in to see how your weeks
going and that type of [ __ ] and you know
we doing this podcast it's usually just
old freckles here talking by himself
acting like a [ __ ] maniac solving
world problems by himself no one to
debate it so it all makes sense and
everyone said well I have a special
guest which I do I do have a special
guest and my special guest as promoted
like a week ago whatever on my podcast
is the one and only Dave eh
drumming sensation teacher sensation
human-being sensation owner of plenty of
t-shirts Dave what's going on dude happy
to be here brother yeah welcome to the
podcast I told you before we started I
made a major [ __ ] on my last podcast
yes I called the band The Specials
the Smiths okay and oh boy no that is
not good at all and I was going on and
on about how much I love this set and
all that and I [ __ ] up and I want to
apologize to everybody actually met the
lead singer of the band and the
guitarist and the lead singer of the
band said he real quick was just like
all right I love the way you say two
word cut say it right it's like the
greatest compliment ever absolutely it's
like when my buddy Joe DeRosa was in
Scotland in a bar at like 4:00 in the
morning and some Scottish guy said there
was like Joe you could [ __ ] and drink
he's just like it was like the greatest
compliment ever so I gotta apologize to
them okay it's it's it's my fault
the [ __ ] music I listen to in the 80s
you know I was in the [ __ ] metal and
all these skater guys and everything up
the street my brother hung out with well
I stopped a mess you know around I'm
like these guys aren't singing about the
devil they're not wearing women's
clothes I'm not listening to these guys
I mean I was you know I was very I was
closed off back then you know so you
know so you saw it you saw and I've been
taking lessons with you for about a year
and a half or so then coming in longer
than
yeah least two right as it felt like ten
going in there I came in there like the
Cryptkeeper like all [ __ ] crunched
over and [ __ ] holding the sticks wrong
for arms everything all jacked up and I
gotta tell you like you're on here
besides the fact that you're a good
friend of mine you're on here because
you have a new a new drum instructional
video route called getting out of your
own way true we've actually got to watch
a lot of last night and it's all this
stuff you know that you've been teaching
me which was about was basically
fighting the kit yourself
yeah I was like yeah I was all crunched
over I was holding the sticks wrong I
was just playing uphill yes nothing was
at the right level and for the drummers
out there who listen to this podcast I
cannot tell you like the stuff that you
showed me just getting me to sit up
straight hold the sticks right and have
[ __ ] where I can hit it yeah due to my
body type yeah it's made so much stuff
that used to be really difficult like
borderline effortless now yeah you know
however I still sucked because at the
end of the day no matter how much you
teach me to sit up straight I am still
at the mercy of the talents that I was
blessed with but I'm but I'm still lean
oh yeah but it's a whole different ball
game than when I first saw you man
I mean you work your ass off - yeah
that's that's it's like I can show you
show people how to do things but if they
don't put in the work
nothing's gonna change you know you work
your ass off so I'm a lunatic Dave yeah
I know I get into [ __ ] that's my point
that's exactly what I'm saying that's
why I always stayed away from hard drugs
because I would have like I'd have like
a [ __ ] monogrammed coke spoon I would
just be I would be a coke heads cokehead
I know if I did it so I try to I try to
send it into positive areas so it's a
good plan well look I gotta ask you I
don't know if I've ever even talked to
this talk to you about this where it's
just like so you grew up in Northern
California mm-hmm you said hell of this
hella dad I'm sure right yes I got made
fun of a lot when I moved to LA
Sacramento Kings fan maybe
I did see the sharks a bit for hockey
when I was I'll [ __ ] I just realized me
this [ __ ] leather chair if this is
gonna make a bunch of noise when I'm
moving around like that Benny Hill
sketch you see that one where he wore
the leather pants the great sketches
every time he had to deliver a line he
would walk across the room and it was
just a sign of his leather pants and he
was sitting down crossing his legs and
then the other person would talk [ __ ]
genius I have to check it out anyways so
when you start what made you like want
to play drums like what got you started
is what what band what band you know I
don't know if there was a I mean I had a
friend who was taking drum lessons and I
like slept over at his house I was like
nine or something and he's like oh my
drum teacher is coming over to give me a
lesson and I was like I'll hang out and
watch and and then I was like oh this
seems fun and then I sat down and I
could just kind of do it like it was
right he was had that gift yeah I can
kind of do this and I never really had
that experience before so I just
immediately got hooked and so I was like
nine or ten so this is like 93 94 right
so this is like god I'm old that was 25
and 26 that's crazy
yeah but this is well dude remember when
we were sending each other YouTube clips
about I sent you that Faith No More clip
and you sent me the was a skid row is
that what it was I don't remember
probably so good I love skid row it was
that it was like SNL performances and it
was like oh my god Skid Row on [ __ ]
SNL and it was like the same year and it
was like check out that we were talking
about the shift in music like right
around like 91 92 I think yeah it was
and it was like how like right when
grunge and all the stuff was coming out
and it was just like hair metal - grunge
was just like you were like what the
[ __ ] it was it was abrupt yes it was
like how a lot of divorces go down in LA
where there's like the day after the
prenup expires BAM divorce papers
like that's the way the musical shift
was but like as a kid I was at that
point like what year was that when I
think it was 91 91 92 yeah
yeah and that's kid role album I [ __ ]
love that album yes they were and they
were crushing crushing yes and
Sebastian's voice was just like just one
of the great front men yes absolutely
of all time and I Ted I didn't see that
shift in music coming I think a way a
lot of those bands didn't wear I because
I remember when Nirvana came out I was
like what the [ __ ] is this and I
couldn't really even hear how good a
band they were or that first video they
had the teen spirit when he was like
doing like a basic solo and he was kind
of acting like he was doing the tap on
solo it was clearly making fun of all
the guys that I liked totally I was like
dude [ __ ] these guys [ __ ] this band and
it wasn't until I saw them on unplugged
and I got in utero and everything and I
was just like wow this these guys are
making like this is a beautiful Alba
night and it took me but it took me like
two and a half years of being like wait
a minute the 80s are over yeah because
I'm old now yeah because you have that
[ __ ] juxtaposed right next to each other
and you're growing from spandex and
lipstick and straightened hair to like
flannel shirts a glam thing was only
about three years okay it was right
around 85 86 everybody got dick started
dressing like men again around 87 88
look everything stop blowing up the hair
let's go back to let's try to get a
little more Allman Brothers here and a
little less grease whatever the [ __ ]
they were doing but so yeah so that was
the scene I was growing up and when I
started playing was what we're talking
about right now
so you missed all of [ __ ] you would just
you know ten years old you I mean I mean
I definitely listen to a shitload of
Phil Collins when I was like a little
Katie's Phil Collins like like the later
stuff that everyone makes fun of no
Sussudio
yeah I mean you know yeah I wasn't like
listening to that song specifically but
like sure about that a little bearded 10
year old Dave dancing around su-su-sudio
I did come out of the womb with a beard
by the way oh you did yeah it's always
been hairy yeah that's why you went to
the drums you can [ __ ] animal that's
true I've heard that more than once did
you uh
so then when when when you uh when all
that grunge stuff came out yeah was that
just sort of music to you as opposed to
me no not like being like oh this is
that you weren't old enough to realize
like wow we just went from this to that
no not at all that's what I'm saying is
like mmm because that happened I
remember listening to cert it's actually
funny like saying this like I listened
to it so much Phil Collins but I would
hear like new waves stuffer or 80 stuff
like tears for four years and be like Oh
gross and now I'd love a law of that
stuff right but at the time it was like
the least cool [ __ ] ever yeah you know I
went back to the 80s a bunch of times
going oh wow this man was actually
pretty good yeah
yeah and it's see and a lot of that
stuff is so like interesting and
esoteric and weird ways that you check
it out now and some of its aged poorly
but some of its aged in like a really
cool way yeah I didn't like a lot of
just the sound yeah [ __ ] that came out
in the 80s whatever that sound was I saw
somebody sent me a video you know about
how they came up with that that sound
for the drums right that was the Phil
Collins you sent me yeah that was just a
complete accident where there was a mic
on in this studio and somebody played a
Phil yeah and it was you know it was it
was in the control room or something
like yeah Phil Collins was apparently
the there's various stories but
apparently fo Collins was playing drums
on one of Peter Gabriel's solo albums
and he was trying out Phil's or whatever
and someone hit the talkback mic so if
you know for people who haven't recorded
in a recording studio when you're in the
control room you hit the talkback mic
and they you can then hear what the
person saying or or if you're in the
studio tracking drums you can't hear
what anyone saying in the control room
right so they have to hit a talkback mic
a button so you can hear what's going on
and basically they went to talk to Phil
and they hit the talkback mic and he
played a drum fill over that and the the
talkback mic picked it up just got super
blown out and they were like whoa that
was crazy I was like a complete accident
and that's how that gated like animated
Gabriel was like I like that sound yeah
and then which was probably I imagined
a cool sound initially and then it was
just overused and then and that's how
everything happens now it's totally like
in vogue again like everyone I mean it's
sort of starting to get overused now but
it just went through a whole thing over
the past five years where that was super
hip again
let's going on in my business right now
where they just they I don't know what's
there just rebooting everything that I
already watched they're just going
they're pouring through IMDB to be like
is this guy still alive do you think he
wants to do who's the boss again a
[ __ ] man who's the boss I don't think
it's something more obscure than that
she's the sheriff that was a show really
the only reason why I know that is
because a friend of mine was on it for a
couple episodes and he said it one night
and was just like dude that's one of the
great [ __ ] references I don't even
know what that is that was a that
beautiful woman who was on Suzanne
Somers hmm she started it and evidently
she was a sheriff she's the sheriff and
she was just this hottie who was the
sheriff and everybody had to listen to
what she did it you know I think was for
like people who are into like dominatrix
and like women telling their piece of
shits and they're under arrest it was
sort of something there was an
underlying sexual thing to everything
that was done back then you know you
can't do any of that now now she'd be a
[ __ ] hero you know and whatever the
[ __ ] whatever the you know the pendulums
completely swung the other way now so
every guy's a [ __ ] taking his dick
out and peeing on a plant blocking a
door and women are all like [ __ ] Joan
of Arc there's no middle ground there's
no middle ground that's what it is we're
gonna go from not listening to women to
not vetting any of them and then saying
every [ __ ] guy is a complete piece of
[ __ ] through some of this [ __ ] that's
come like some of these guys get friends
of mine now it's like literally
ex-girlfriends who are mad that they're
famous now totally out just coming out
going like our lives get ruined they're
like I don't like you anymore if I'm
gonna ruin your life I mean well the
fact that this if you're if there's
gonna be no due process I mean who is
safe yeah no one it's crazy yeah yeah it
was emotionally abusive it's a I've got
it I've got emotionally abused and like
at least 85% of my relationships I spent
the last [ __ ] week in my own [ __ ]
house on eggshells
we're back in a good place but it's just
constantly you know the emotional abuse
I mean women have the [ __ ] market
cornered on that this is this is a
different podcast so anyways that's a
different topic so your your your your
your instructional videos yeah you put
it out first of all you know you're
already ahead of 90% of people just by
the way it looks the quality of the way
it's shot because so much of it is just
somebody you know literally wearing a
GoPro staring into a mirror why they
play drums that you're supposed to try
to [ __ ] learn something that's well
that's exactly why I made this thing I
mean I've been teaching for you know
like 20 years and I worked with you know
a lot of pros a lot of my contemporaries
a lot of big-name dudes who are out in
the real world touring with big bands in
addition to me touring and recording and
I never you know I always wanted to do
an instructional thing but with the way
technologies evolved with Instagram and
YouTube and everything like everyone's a
quote-unquote teacher now yeah so oh by
the way there's so there's this inside
thing that I always see something I
think it's [ __ ] amazing a drum thing
and then I send it to you and you just
like and you know they're my field is
what I you know is when people come up
to me and then they just picked like
some somebody super popular at the
moment like what do you think is
so-and-so that purse is really funny hon
you gotta be like yeah yeah they're on
stage doing things they're yeah they're
saying things reacting with laughter you
just have to say straight-up facts yeah
I know I would I do I just like I would
never take down another comic publicly
but on the phone with my friends
what's it is we [ __ ] eviscerate so
many people and then eventually it comes
around to us and then we just start
trashing each other and just laughing
our ass off and then the end everyone we
trash we just go oh yeah god bless yeah
that's what it's all about I do that
same [ __ ] to I have text threads with
friends of mine where we do the same
same thing and we're just as brutal to
work to each other into ourselves do you
know how many jokes like back in the day
when I when I was working the commies
New York how many jokes I lost how many
shirts I could never wear again and all
of this because we should just sit there
and like the guys used to go down and
they would watch you on stage and they
would be staring at you with liked it
would be Patrice rest his soul heath
voss Norton and they would just stand in
there in the doorway we could see none
of the crowd could see man you had to
like totally commit to your [ __ ] act
Wow
and I remember Kevin Hart when he first
[ __ ] came down he's like 20 years old
and they were doing that to him and I
remember he didn't get rattled he did a
little bit and then the first time and
then he didn't after once he didn't get
rattled and I remember thinking like wow
man this kid is he's got the force wow
you know yeah because I was sitting
there those guys were all my
contemporaries sure we were like 10 15
years older than Kevin huh these guys
are my contemporaries and I could if I
was like oh god they're gonna stare at
me and then you almost felt like you
deliberately had to say something to
bomb or some [ __ ] like that so I don't
know do you guys ever do stuff like do
you ever watch this go out see if like
for a comedian to watch a [ __ ] a friend
a yours bomb if not if it's like a if it
does set means something but regice up
there and they try a joke and they just
eat shits one of the funniest things
ever do like when you watch a friend of
yours play drums they go for a fill or
something if they eat [ __ ] on it yeah
it's totally different just just by the
nature of what you're doing so much of
it is just throwing [ __ ] against the
wall and seeing what sticks and just
being like hey I [ __ ] try you're like
that's I love comedians and I respect me
and so much because you know I'll go
around town and see you or other
brothers go out one night and go to the
comedy store or something and someone
will walk up on stage weather slope I've
seen you do this and a bunch of other
people like oh yeah just like I was
working some [ __ ] out oh yeah you know
like object like that didn't [ __ ]
work you know and like that you can't do
that with music like people are there to
see a show and it might watch something
it's like what about the the Jam section
you guys call it we look at each other
then you just wait and like there are
but there are like this did this don't a
different musical salute there's some
bands go on it like we're playing
exactly like the record sure and then
there's other people like if we play it
like the record one more time I'm gonna
blow my brains out
yeah absolutely and there's sort of
something else in situations where you
can jam and improvise and you know like
I would do that with the Mars Volta or
like or like anti master every certain
sections where we just go way out into
outer space for half an hour what was
that like when you got that gig and and
you had to follow it was crazy all of
those amazing drummers that were in the
band all this [ __ ] that they came up
with and didn't you haven't like
something ridiculously short amount of
time they have to learn it and all that
yeah basically I got the call to do it
and and wond the the bass player who
used to play bass in Racer X okay I'm
sure I'll [ __ ] up their name on the next
well talked about 80s and spandex and
feathered hair they're pretty deep into
that scene but yeah so Juan came over to
my studio with fellow bass player this
guy Jonathan hickey really good buddy of
mine now and John came over just to
watch me like so so Wong came over like
we plugged in my ipod and he's like you
know this song you know and I'm like I
don't know I've never played along this
stuff I just kind of like the first
record so Juan's playing with me and
John's just sitting there like two feet
in front of me just staring at me
watching me like and then Jesus Christ
yeah I know it's stressful and and I
never played the music I was just like I
kind of know this thing or well you know
just from being a fan of what sort of a
CREP did you do before then nothing it
was like hey I'm lying I'm in line at
Starbucks when he called me and then I
had to go to a recording session all day
and then I was like I can meet you after
I'm done with this session at night and
then he was like okay and like that you
know what I mean how bad did you need
that mars volta gig know in your career
was that something it was huge yes yeah
it really put me on the map I mean
because of the lineage of dudes that
were in that band and how like the
reputation that band has I mean I'd done
things before that but nothing of that
level you know so it was huge so I had
about two weeks you know to learn the
music and it was a two and a half hour
set you know yeah and so what do
what did you do shot it out yeah I
charted everything out how longs it take
you to and when when like how true to
the original like John Theodore well
yeah well I'd loved I'd love John's
playing I think he's amazing and I think
his parts are incredible I think that
first record is really a masterpiece so
I wanted to do everything that I could
in the time that I had to play
everything note-for-note
because I think that's really important
but that it's like it's like what
situation we were talking about earlier
like people go to see those songs off
that first record and they want it
exactly right like I would want to see
that so I went out of my way to get
everything totally note-for-note which
you know was easier and more difficult
in some certain circumstances but there
were other you know other songs where it
wasn't really important as much so two
and a half weeks to get it together and
and like how often were you jamming with
the band I didn't meet the band until I
got to Amsterdam and then we I mean me
and Omar the guitar player and Juan like
got the three of us jammed a little bit
you know I went down to Mexico and the
three of us played through the
arrangements and it was like he was like
yeah this is Omar's like this is fine
like you're fine but then I went to
Amsterdam how much of a relief was it to
hear that well we we rehearsed
everything without vocals which is
difficult because I used vocals to like
sort of know where I am in the song a
lot oh yeah I've made that mistake so he
was like dude you only you know you
don't even need to be here this is fine
it's all good and I was like okay great
but you're still like freaking out you
know so I get to Amsterdam meet the rest
of the band and we run through the set
and this is kind of funny cuz I I wrote
out all my charts and I put an extra
floor tom on my left and like a crash
cymbal on my left like the left of the
hi-hat and I just put my charts on the
floor Tom like hoping like no one would
see you know right and I get up halfway
through and to go to the bathroom and I
came back it was all gone Oh somebody
took a yeah and I like look over it wani
like dude you don't need that [ __ ]
you're good and I was like okay and then
everything was fine
we ran out really hot ran through the
two and a half hours cuz there's a lot
of visual cues I was gonna say but if
they're like that yeah if they if you
went there and they weren't during the
first rehearsal wanting it note for note
there must been
something a little bit easier where it's
like okay these guys aren't gonna be
like Nazis about this I think they'd be
room for me to kind of yeah pull based
on the situation sort of where they were
coming the situation they were coming
out of they were so like exhausted so
they were just like you know this is
this sounds like they were basically
like we sound like a band again this
sounds like a record
oh cool which is great because I did
that first gig yeah what was that was a
it was in Oslo I love that those people
a great comedy fence oh my god
some of my [ __ ] lunatic some of my
all-time best friends are from are from
Oslo so many of them and so many amazing
musicians from there it's insane my
first really good show I ever had in
Europe was in Oslo really I don't know
if it was them or I just find was just
like just because I was too much in my
head huh in other places like I'm in a
different country are they going to get
this I'm talking about shirts do they
have shirts yes they do they are wearing
shirts oh [ __ ] my timing is completely
up and I was so [ __ ] fed up with
mediocre sets I think that when I was in
Oslo I just didn't give a [ __ ] yeah and
then they were also like picked up on it
no they were kind of maniacs where they
were like drinking and [ __ ] like oh
these are the kind of people how are
they just kind of I felt comfortable and
and then the rest of the tour then I
went into Stockholm and all that and
just everything else after sort of fell
into places Oh just act like you're here
which I wonder in Oslo
no no act like I'm in America oh oh oh
yeah cuz then even if they don't get it
you get to play the arrogant American a
fickle you should know everything about
my country and I shall know nothing
about yours and they almost want you to
say that because you you feed into their
stereotype of like yes they are
self-involved [ __ ] and we're better
than they are and they love it I jump
around a lot in the okay I get it it's
not like I've never listened to this
before yeah it's a [ __ ] show
so that first show yeah I mean I was
insanely nervous but it went fine and
then as soon as I was like halfway
through the show I remember I was
like yeah I'm feeling good like I'm
gonna try and like put on a little bit
of a show here like visually right
because that's always very important to
me like there's nothing more boring than
seeing someone just up there just like
looking like they're doing their taxes
that's me not anymore a little bit
better oh my god holy [ __ ] we got to
talk about videotaping yourself while
playing drums which you made me do oh my
god my self-esteem has never been lower
I've never looked worse doing anything
ever even my early stand-up tapes which
I have on VHS which I can't even watch I
don't look as bad yeah cuz he weren't
slouching you know like but you won't so
you don't slide this you know you don't
slouch when you when you walk around and
when you when you do stand up it's when
you sit down that you slap no but
actually you know something what i
postulate being [ __ ] up yeah is all my
weight is on my knees and i've noticed a
lot of people do this when they stand up
they actually they're there their hips
are forward and you're sort of leaning
back like standing like this and what
you're actually supposed to do you like
to stand up totally straight like this
okay I feel like I'm puffing my chest
acting like you want to [ __ ] fight
yes especially coming from where I grew
up in such an angry crazy state isn't
outside of Boston forget about Boston
itself I was in the suburbs and that
[ __ ] was [ __ ] nuts yeah you stand up
straight and then your knees are just
slightly bent and your arms are just
hanging down and your shoulders are a
little you know I feel like they're back
but they're not that just lines exactly
this is what I have to like learn how to
do but this is exactly what I've said to
you and what I say to everyone
especially all these big big name
working pros is it's like if you're
slouching that's your sort of normal go
to setting' and you think that that's
you sitting up straight right so that
when you sit up straight or stand up
straight it feels like you're puffing
your chest out cuz ya hog 'native
disconnect yes or rewire everything so
it's much more accurate so that's that's
the thing when I work on all this
technique body mechanics stuff with
people like that's why I tell them to
videotape themselves because you can't
tell what you actually
look like ya know it's brutal I know and
it's brutal for everyone it's brutal for
everyone including me it's never it
never gets easy so when something I
started to talk about so when you were
you started playing drums and everything
yeah I imagine you just sat down and
grabbed the sticks the way any other kid
would have like when did you start to
break down what you would do did you get
hurt or did you just see a video of some
guy where he made it look effortless
good question I think when I started
getting really serious when I was like
14 or 15 it was a matter of me just
constantly going how lazy can I possibly
be like how can I play all the stuff I
want to play and just be is like how
like how much how can I continually just
make this easier on myself like why
would I do this if I could just do that
instead why do you think he thought that
I don't know uh maybe I'm just lazy no I
was gonna say to me you're not you're a
driven guy sure III think I've just
became obsessed with like efficiency not
like for the sake of it in and of itself
but to be like I can play more or say
more or do more the more efficient I am
there's more I can do it's more I can
say alright a moat that way maybe it
comes from you know my dad collects cars
maybe it comes from growing up and that
culture of like talking about you know
how you know a different scene like a
hammy and a wedge you know like the
different having dual spark plugs versus
single like I don't know I mean maybe it
all is it sort of mashed up together I
think it's just I you know if I wanted
to play everything and I realized from a
young age probably subconsciously like I
need to be as efficient as possible so
I'm not getting in my own way so I can
play the stuff I want to play you know
it's like the first time you heard
becoming you know the Pantera song first
time I heard it I had to put it on a
cassette tape and put it in a handheld
recorder and slow the speed down right I
remember standing in my mom's kitchen
putting it up to my pump up to my ear
slowing this bead down going what the
[ __ ] is going on right now right like
having no clue how he could possibly do
that physically and then just sitting
there and breaking it down
well that wouldn't I still feel a lot of
it that way about a lot of this stuff
which by the way man you got to give a
shout-out to Vinnie good Lord man that I
was literally talking about a texting
with you dope
cuz I'm talking on the phone yeah and I
was just going like why is this guy so
[ __ ] good in like two hours later you
sent me the text that he had passed away
[ __ ] brutal I know man I was really
but I haven't been that bummed out and I
haven't been like affected that much by
someone's death like who I didn't really
know him at once you know right but I
mean he was a real hero of mine and unto
a lot of people and he just had such a
commitment to a very specific aesthetic
like he's like this is the sound this is
the feel this is the vibe and like I'm a
hundred percent committed like and the
fact that they were doing that when all
this [ __ ] that I was talking about that
I was less to do that just face-planted
and then all this grunge came out and
they were just like now yeah we're gonna
keep doing this
that's like great Southern Trendkill
that's that records about as them being
like to [ __ ] all these trends like [ __ ]
this grunge [ __ ] like we're gonna stay
true to our metal roots you just keep
doing this like all that on that live
record that live hundred and one proof
record like I love that dude Phil
Anselmo is in between song banter is
incredible oh it's hilarious [ __ ]
people out there so we couldn't [ __ ]
Charlotte number one [ __ ] album on
that [ __ ]
I always [ __ ] love you man good
Hargett Larry do props from our [ __ ]
it's just like all this [ __ ] thing if
you said it now you'd be my favorite
thing I always talk about on this is
when when when Vinnie counts off I'm
broken yeah it's like in the middle of
Phil talking it's like why wrong Minaj
called on broke and I'm Avenue grinning
yeah I'm having a good job and diamonds
already playing and it was just like did
they do that cuz that was [ __ ] cool
or was Vinnie like oh god shut up I want
a drink I think it was part of the show
yeah I think he was probably just like
[ __ ] here we go
you know
I love that that's such a great moment
in that record cuz you could tell
they're just [ __ ] having fun dude and
that's why it should that's part of the
reason why that [ __ ] feels I never went
to go see them because I heard the music
and I had an idea in my head what the
crowd was gonna be like I'm gonna get
the [ __ ] kicked outta me
but that's one of the funny things I was
just talking to a buddy of mine Jamie
who I've been giving Skype lessons to in
London in every week for years and he
was telling me he went to see the Bronx
the other day recently oh it's like you
know pretty heavy like punk rock band
and he said like he brought his wife and
she was like they let they they've had a
great time at the show and like everyone
you know someone falls down in the pit
someone picks him up like everyone's
looking out for each other and he said
like they left the show and his wife was
like or he said I forget they were like
we felt more unsafe walking the streets
that you did at that show
like with all these dudes beating the
[ __ ] out of each other yeah it just
sounded like when I listen to their
music there's a bunch of guys that were
mad at their dad we're gonna show up and
then they were gonna take the childhood
out on me I just you know and I had
[ __ ] orange hair it was like I just
didn't think it was gonna end well so
it's just like but that is one of my big
regrets that I didn't there was a number
of those bands that I didn't go out and
go see because I was just like dude I
love this music but I'm gonna go I'm
gonna get the [ __ ] [ __ ] kicked out of
me and you know I was also when my
[ __ ] my stupid single bass drum
Bonham did Adobe pedal the music didn't
require it bill
I don't care he could do more with one
foot did this guy just saying all this
[ __ ] that lot of people and just
completely ignoring this entirely new
type of drumming and in all of these
pioneers yeah who were just there was
like there was no roadmap on what to do
when I was listening to all these other
[ __ ] guys who were just saying [ __ ]
that had already been said and like
basically if you could have a foot as
fast as bottom right and you were bottom
something like that me this way my head
was but this is what I love doing when
we're doing lessons together and just
shooting the [ __ ] or whatever is is is
that massive amount of carryover between
drumming and
and of Comedy I mean it's oh yeah it's
huge and that's what so forth no
difference it's the exact same [ __ ]
thing of like you know the difference
between a guy who changed comedy versus
a guy who's just sort of you know doing
comedy or or if you just if you're on
stage like just reciting your act versus
being up there and having an idea and
the crowd reacts one way which actually
affects how the show goes
everything and I used to be so envious
of musicians that could just sit down
and play what they could feel or react
to what another musician did and I just
did not have that ability so when I got
into stand-up I remember like stand-up I
had the same feeling you had like when
you got down when you said it at a kid
when I first time I remember when I went
to was my second show is that this place
stitches comedy club which no longer
exists and I went in there for this open
mic and I remember just walking into all
of these open my kurz up at the bar all
in different levels and I just
remembered feeling like like like for
the first time like I was with a
demographic of people that like I I
didn't know I was just like yeah these
guys are the same kind of [ __ ] weird
that I am yeah this these weirdos feel
normal to me and it was the first time
when I want to stand up you know even
though I obviously had to learn from all
these people they was I I had like this
feeling of I know I don't really know
exactly where I'm going but I kind of
know where I'm going like I know that I
just have to do this a bunch of times
right and what I feel in me is is like
that this is the right thing it is going
to kind of come out and so when I'm in
the one of the first guys I ever saw
just wing a set I saw this guy Frank
Santorelli hmm and he went up there and
knowing what I know now about comedy I
think it was because the host brought
him up and they were playing this weird
music and she started doing this dumb
dance and he did it with her and he had
this totally serious look on his face he
was already killing before I even took
the mic out of the mics damn ha but I
think that little improv exercise
opened him up and he just went up there
and it was like he was just [ __ ]
talking and and I'd seen his act a bunch
of timbre and and then I remember
thinking like oh he should he should do
that again he should do like everything
was so precious you gotta hang on to
every Friday thing you ever said it
wasn't it like listened to the musicians
were that whole those types of bands
where it's just like yeah this is how
the song came out that night that was
the mood we were in right and I remember
trying like I try to apply that yeah cuz
it's the exact same thing I have people
say it's still hard at what you do cuz
you wake up you know you're a baby mama
dad dad you're already playing you're
already taught I'm just talking into a
microphone I have to learn how to speak
yeah but you through sounds yeah but put
an instrument put you being able to
stand up and wing a set you have to be
just funny inherently funny obviously
takes work but you have to be a funny
person to be able to do that as opposed
to someone who has all you do is when if
it doesn't work you just make fun of
yourself it's the it's the it's like
literally you know if you can't dance
you just learn a little two-step and let
the woman do all the [ __ ] work and
sing it's over it's the same [ __ ]
thing you go up there you wing an idea
if it doesn't either just make fun of
yourself or you blame the crowd yeah but
that's like she's saying like oh yeah
when I go to do a drum solo it's like
yeah I just kind of played the Tom's a
little bit and then the cymbal no it is
it's I'm sorry it isn't yeah so I'm
saying the same thing to you all right
it's it's not that easy
like I mean but that's the you know I
have you know dudes who I teach you or
like mainly touring guys like pop acts
or whatever they're like I can sit down
and play the [ __ ] out of a show like
from start to finish nail everything but
if I sit down and someone's like hey
play a little bit like I don't know what
the [ __ ] to do I can't just play by
myself yeah and that's the same also
type of a thing
someone has a routine their bits a show
put together they could kill it but then
if they just walk up and if somebody
heckles them and [ __ ] up yeah it did
yep I guess that's exactly the same in
music and comedy someone throws a
[ __ ] beer bottle at you or whatever
people throw [ __ ] at you guys that does
not have I mean I've had [ __ ] thrown at
me but like I usually deserved it you
guys would just be up there singing and
for some reason somebody just wants to
throw a
bought like I don't like a lot of times
it's like the band is like the crowd is
enjoying the show it's like they just
want to connect with you yes I hit him
with the bottle like the plastic water
bottle I was drinking and my
fingerprints were on it and it touched
him so yeah and then he yelled at me it
was epic people are crazy
what um what's the most fucked-up thing
you ever saw in a show cuz you're the
drummer you get to see that have you
ever said your lead singer go to crowd
surf and just sort of disappear in the
crowd and the people can't find him and
you guys are looking each other like how
are we gonna end this song you know one
of the most brutal things I ever saw it
was I wasn't involved I was just a
spectator but I was seeing I think it
was with some sort it was some Mike
Patton band you see like Melvin's or
Fond Tomas or he's in that dead cross
now right yeah yeah yeah I got to see
them Bart oh yeah yeah
I can't remember who it was anyway they
brought up like jello biafra
like sing a song and he went to go like
this is maybe five ten years ago and he
went to go like state like stage-dive or
whatever his first step he took he said
that done some girl's face oh no and
then just ate [ __ ] it's like Family Guy
fall how it's like one frame and then
your arms are behind your back oh [ __ ]
and it was it just like took him like
ten minutes to get back on stage and it
was just like and what is the band doing
were they just playing it kept playing
and you know it's just like Oh God
brutal so what do you do does the guitar
player play a solo like how do you eat I
mean I think they just kept you know
Patton was up there I think they just
kept like going you know and he
eventually made his way back on stage or
whatever but it was just like BAM yeah I
mean maybe like for me playing there's a
drum cam video on on on YouTube things
the first thing you saw of me the Volt
the Goliath oh yeah and I didn't
understand your technique I'm like this
guy's [ __ ] arms are gonna fall off
yeah yeah I was going apeshit and going
nuts and hitting super hard and or it
looks like I'm hitting hard
and one thing Cedric used to love to do
is he would just like take my crash
cymbals away from me like so there's a
part in that video where he just takes
my crash and I only have two so he takes
my crash and then like you know like
basically just jumps on it and like
throws it up and down and then takes the
cymbal off and stomps on it and then
takes the cymbal stand and throws it
like over my head and almost hit takes
out the camera and I'm like this is the
this was the first time he'd ever done
this so like did you know that he did
[ __ ] like no no I mean not really I
don't think so did you think it was
because of your playing no he was just
like rock and rock'n'roll
you know okay yeah my [ __ ]
self-esteem would be like he hates me
I'm getting fired and then I'd be
getting mad be like dude [ __ ] trash
my [ __ ] well I did get mad eventually
and my company was like what the [ __ ]
but anyway yeah they had to keep sending
you yeah there were like [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] we send you symbols to play not to
get broken by the lead singer you know
so so yeah this is the first time you
ever did it so you can see me like
turning around to my tech like hey
[ __ ] give me another symbol and a
Stan look come on dude like and and he's
like hold on a sec you know and then and
then he was just like I gotta make sure
and wait till he's actually done you
don't know how far he's gonna take this
oh yeah yeah wait till he's out of that
mood yeah and then he eventually you
know eventually brought another one up
and it was fine but like well not to get
into the gossip we were able to just
kind of sit there and say hey buddy I
love being in the band man but I need my
cymbals yeah I mean I got to a certain
point where I was like dude like really
you know like come on cuz he actually
plays drums too I was like you know you
know how much you know annoying that
that would be right you know he's like
all [ __ ] yeah you're right sorry man
it's getting carried away you know I
said when I was if I if I ever saw that
on TV or if I was in the crowd or
whatever when I was a kid and I was
playing drums and everything I used to
just be a dick you just give it to me
right right I need a cymbal right
totally
you just have to ever just break it in
front of me it's just like if I would've
loved to have had that yeah like when I
ever watch like the who or whatever yeah
and it was funny because I don't know if
they just had like some piece of [ __ ]
you know the Japanese version of the
less well whatever if it was an actual
one he now like all those vintage
instruments how much they're worth like
Ike Pete Townsend his probably you know
know my god probably seven figures and
guitars I would think Oh at least yeah
yeah my buddy my buddy Jerry plays with
Dick Dale you know and he brings out
this like I don't know what it is if
it's like an explorer or Les Paul or
something but it's like from the 50s and
his amp is also from the 50s and it's
like that shit's worth several hundred
thousand dollars yes any tours with it
well yeah he's a guy who to plays off
rock but he plays like a right handed
guitar left the upside down and doesn't
change the strings that sounds right to
me yeah he does something super [ __ ]
up and weird yeah that's all that that
Pulp Fiction song yep that's it yeah
okay yeah well where can people get this
video you know they've mentioned they
can go to my website just de village
calm so your name blip dumb weird um
over here li TCH Dave elix calm and you
just click on instructional course it'll
pop up there and you can get everything
there it's just streaming and you know I
everybody does these sort of
subscription-based courses now and then
they just take your money forever my and
I didn't want to do that so I'm like you
know you just pay for it once you stream
it forever as long as you want
yeah I'm not gonna charge a credit card
for seven years you know like I don't
want to do that so I've had a couple of
those yeah then you forget you have
exactly a somebody's looking at your
stuff going like dude what the [ __ ] is
this did I ever tell you I had I had a
cell phone number for like 15 years that
I never used are you serious yeah like I
was bitching up to my wife going like is
that mine no worries I was paying just
seemed like a ton of money all of a
sudden for my cell phone it just kept
going up and up and up I understand why
I'm paying why am i paying so much more
than [ __ ] it was going up to like
[ __ ] three four hundred bucks right
so she goes let me see it and she looked
at it she goes alright first of all I
think it's a three cell phone numbers
why yes she's looking at me yeah like I
like I got like [ __ ] chicks on the
side and I'm like no I don't know we
looked at I is what it was back in the
day when you were on the road you know
in you bring you your [ __ ] big
thick laptop or whatever and all these
hotel rooms were charging anywhere from
7-10 eleven dollars a day for the
internet right so I wouldn't I was
working places Tuesday through Sunday so
it was like six times you know ten
eleven bucks it was like costing man
with the tax it's cost me like $70 to be
on the Internet
so my buddy Robert Kelly he's like dude
would you want to do dude he knows all
the [ __ ] technology because dude you
get to [ __ ] it's this was this hot
spot right things so it had its own
number you plugged it in to your
computer you know in blah blah blah
right so I tried to use it twice and it
never worked no says these [ __ ]
things never [ __ ] work and I knew in
the back of my head it's like I gotta
call these guys up and cancel it or
whatever and I just I just never did and
I just forgot about it
oh and recently I actually found it I
still have the thing so that was one of
them I forget what the other one was but
but it was like two things that were of
that one was like a fax machine number
and the other was like all those
outdated [ __ ] so she got she got that
taken off and then I think one time when
I left the country I switched my plan
and they didn't quite switch it back or
something so now it's down to like a
buck 80 a month it was your mobile hot
spot like the size of this fridge no you
know it was the size of a hockey puck I
mean it was big was a big plastic thing
and you just had and you had to come up
with all the stuff that trips me up you
know you got to come up with a password
and just like just a couple to three of
those hoops that I have to jump through
but yeah that's too much but I've been
working all lately though I'm ever
seeing maybe I was watching one of the
interviews you did or whatever you said
how you think everyone should have a
therapist if you just talk to somebody
does the world be a better place well I
haven't gone to therapy and like I
finally at one point I was just going
like dude I'm always gonna be [ __ ] up
I can sit here like I'm done talking
about my childhood so I'm just gonna be
talking about the dumb [ __ ] that happens
every day like this feels started
feeling a reality show but one on one
reality show but recently I've really
been working on my not snapping over
little things hmm and I started to snap
this morning for the first time in like
four days and it actually felt a little
weird
I'm gonna keep trying to do what I'm
doing with it and I keep talking about
it aloud so I remember it because you
know it's okay I'm gonna go to the gym
yeah I know and then that week you
[ __ ] crush it next week you
three-quarter you crush it a month later
your feet norio sitting on a couch so
what are you so what are you doing like
you just like breathe deeply yours like
when I well big thing is driving sure so
when I get in the [ __ ] car I just say
like first of all I leave enough [ __ ]
time to get there
I don't leave the Utopia time this
should take a half hour nope how dare
these other people in front of me have
other plans in other lives so I leave
plenty of time and then I just weird
I Drive slow slower I'm probably driving
somebody nuts behind drive slower I stop
at yellow lights I let people go hide
shell out I actually there's another
thing I swear to god this is like they
use this for premature ejaculation I'm
actually using this I listen to baseball
these day think I'll think about
baseball I never understood that if you
don't want to [ __ ] bust a nut I start
thinking of [ __ ] car Yastrzemski now
[ __ ] get a hard dick thinking about
the [ __ ] left-field or the Red Sox
and it's just confusing it's like wait
am i attracted to this guy I just didn't
feel like you were present sorry I was
sorry I was thinking about [ __ ] at
Jerry Remy no I put on like there's
something about smoking a cigar and
listening to listening to baseball on a
radio is like some old man [ __ ] and it
slows life down I don't know what it is
so I I just have it on and they just
have a wonderful day for a ball game and
there's the lineups bla bla bla bla bla
you know it's just next inning is
brought to you by and you just sort of
drift along and I just and I just know
and I just I don't have I hate saying
this but you know you that the people
always say like you know you got to give
up like expectations and [ __ ] first of
all I also like googled how to stop
snapping over little things and the
first thing I clicked on was this woman
going did you ever have
did you have a blood and say everything
that I've done like yes yes yes yes yes
so she goes here's four techniques and
I'm reading this [ __ ] and I am like five
minutes into reading this and before she
says you know I've been doing this for
like a week and I'm like what literally
started snapping like you don't change
in a week okay this is this is gonna
take me I just turned 50 this will take
if I work my ass off this will take all
of my 50s to not to not do this that's
why I was joking with a buddy of mine
why one of the most realistic ters ever
in any movie was was private hooks in
police academy remember she's always all
mousy that black girl hanging and then
the end she'd be like and I remember
joking you know every movie she'd go
back to being mousy again she had the
exact same character arc and it's just
like when is she you know and in reality
is is that's what it's like to try to
change yourself as a person is you have
you know [ __ ] out [ __ ] up [ __ ]
up for 90 minutes and then whatever or
whatever how much time the move goes by
in the movie and then you had that
breakthrough moment and you don't move
dirtbag and then the next day you know
you're gonna fall back again
oh maybe two days later whatever so yeah
but that that's the but but when you you
know if you continue to do that work on
yourself where you fall back isn't as
far down the ladder as you were before
you know yeah no no yeah believe me to
like I'm I am committed to this because
it's gonna make my relationship with my
wife so much better I'm telling you dude
if I can just stop snapping at little
[ __ ] dude she's got nothing she's got
nothing no because what I'm still doing
this is something else that I'm gonna
I'm starting to let go of is there's a
way when you're in a relationship with
the woman like thinking the way a guy
thinks you think I'm gonna do this and
then it's gonna then it's then she's
gonna be happy with me and she'll be in
a good mood and then I'll the eggshells
go away right and what you realize is
that that that's
you're chasing a that's it's like a
Ponzi scheme like there's there's no
meaning having expectations for your
actions is no I just like I'm just
always going to annoy or inherently just
because I'm a man and I'm not gonna see
things the way she does cuz she's a
woman
and what what she views is important
versus what I view as or she views is
not a big deal and I think is a big deal
he's not gonna mesh not because she's a
bad person or I'm a bad person it's just
because we are wired differently hmm and
so I forget what something happened just
this morning and I started to get upset
and I was just like what why would I
think that she would bla bla bla and it
just [ __ ] went away that's great
so I can't but I'm afraid of this
because now I'm feel like I'm just
become this spineless guy you know
sitting there holding her purse you know
what I talk about the same [ __ ] I have
with my with my therapist a bunch of
times because coming not even
necessarily talking about that specific
thing as a human being but talking about
that specific thing as being the source
of your creativity in some way yeah you
know what I mean like that's that know
there's dude there is a thing with
comedians was if I get happy I won't be
funny which is what musicians - it's a
huge myth because I'll tell you why what
happens is is like once you get
everything you want you know as far as
like you found love and you have the kid
and your kid comes home is going done
big smiles dude it's the [ __ ]
greatest greatest [ __ ] thing ever
it's one of the few things in the world
that lives up to the hype right other
than downloading your [ __ ] video boom
BAM cross-promoting what at what
replaces all your angst and loneliness
and sleeping on a futon and [ __ ] isn't
this new fear of that you're now gonna
lose it all right like what if something
happens like I can't tell you since
having a kid like any new scenario like
hey I'm gonna go take her on this swing
like immediately
this horror movie that Stephen King
could not [ __ ] with or maybe that maybe
he has kids or something that's how he
writes but like
[ __ ] that goes through your head about
the possible stuff that would happen and
always in the end I'm either murdering a
person or an animal one of the other
dude I've actually had fantasies of
jumping down on a Cougars back and
somehow I know that UFC move will you
choke it out and I wrap my legs around
its belly so I can't claw me and I sit
there while I'm eating his sandwich
thinking of all of this because my wife
said that she's gonna like just take her
out in the backyard yeah yeah so all of
that and then like those [ __ ] crazy
thoughts will then will then fuel your
um your act hopefully so anyways well I
I have to I got to read a little bit
advertising okay you want to see some
comedy here once again my apologies to
the specials men I I feel so [ __ ] bad
about that and I told I told the singer
I'd throw a couple of constant for him
and then I called his band The Smiths
and then I had all these [ __ ] mopey
Morrissey people he left that bad thirty
years ago man they're never getting back
and other people freaking out did they
get back together like I caused like
this whole [ __ ] thing I feel like
such by the way your your you need to
film like a video of your Morrissey
dance
oh the Morrissey dance oh yeah they've
not done that yet no I gotta get it down
better it's one of my favorite things
I've ever seen I don't dislike Morrissey
I just made like irritating people that
are really into [ __ ] like Star Wars fans
I saw then I saw one I saw one of the
newer Star Wars ones it was [ __ ]
great it was actually really good now
that it's not like a muppet movie like
it was to like it was like it was like
Muppets with space and then some bad
self help you know this guy's good isn't
he's in the lead his lightsabers blue
dude I think Star Wars is great but when
people like make their lives revolve
around it I just it's like there's so
much other [ __ ] out there in the world
that's why people don't like baby
boomers because baby boomers like they
just make so much about what they grew
up in and [ __ ] yeah the stuff they did
if they just [ __ ] just did what they
did and just shut the [ __ ] up about it
other generations realize how cool they
were they would have been fine all right
I got to read a couple these things here
all right okay bill stitch fixed sent
you clothes while you were in Paris
they're actually really normal and
wearable and much better than the other
clothing companies we've had I probably
shouldn't read that out loud
all right this is gonna be I guess these
guys make really normal wearable clothes
okay yeah that was the sound of money
going out the door
stitch fix everybody convenience stitch
fix understands that how much [ __ ]
copy this is this is like an that's a
novel stitch fix understands that life
gets busy so tell tell them your sizes
and your favorite type of clothes and
how you want to spend and your personal
stylists will pick out clothing for you
based on your preferences try before
buying if an item doesn't fit or you
don't like it no worries just send it
back free of charge no clue what you did
in those clothes they must have a giant
washing machine that it just goes in
some guy in a hazmat suit shows up style
some of us have it some of us don't but
just because a sense of style seems
elusive for some doesn't mean it's
impossible to attain there's no time
like the present to discover the style
you never knew you had with somebody
else's talent and you can with a little
help from our friends at stitch fix that
it's not somebody else's talent this is
reminding me of every bad 80s movie will
they do like a makeover on you stitch
fix has reinvented how we find and buy
clothes just answer some basic questions
about your sizes favorite styles and
budget right from your laptop smartphone
or tablet your personal stylist then
springs into action hand selecting five
brand new clothes
item for you I know I know personal
stylist sounds like something only the
rich and famous can afford but you can
too stitch fix styling fee is only $20
which is applied as a credit toward
anything you keep and since your
personal stylist uses only prep your
preference is to pick your clothes
you're still in complete control once
your item arrive try them on and only
pay what you want to keep don't like
something need normal size just send the
items back this way I don't think I'm
supposed to read all this because they
just keep repeating the same [ __ ] no
questions asked and the shipping is
always free both ways get your fix
whatever you want or sign up
receive scheduled shipments the choice
is yours
I love stitch fish fix Dave I didn't
realize that I guess I do because they
have normal wearable clothes I'm sure
these are great I'm sure these are great
and I know you will to call to action
hurry to stitch Fitch stitch fix comm
slash Bertie get started now keep all
five items in your box and you'll get
twenty five twenty five percent off your
entire purchase
that's stitch fix comm / burr stitch fix
comm / / hey what do you thinks gonna
happen all the strip malls and malls in
the future like what are we gonna do
with those cuz there's gonna be no
stores like because everybody's shopping
from the internet online yeah even like
they'll buy like a vintage guitar
without even [ __ ] trying it out me
and have it show up and realize that it
isn't and the guys in Japan there's
nothing you can do about he's got your
money I remember I bought that what you
know that Prince album that that really
uh the one Questlove always talks about
where it was just like it was I think
was just an all-black album it's not
available like he put it out and no I
don't know yeah I bought it off some guy
in Japan I don't know what showed up it
was like the [ __ ] soundtrack to chips
and what am I gonna do call it PayPal
they're gonna find him hey man we're a
web country in the United States and
unless you return that [ __ ] money for
that record we will we will do
absolutely nothing cuz you'll just
change your name and become somebody
else
all right policy genius if you have a
car you have insurance you have car
insurance we should at least if you have
a home you have home insurance if you're
alive should you have life insurance
four out of ten people don't have life
insurance at all and it's not their
fault its life insurance fault shopping
for life insurance is confusing and it
takes forever hey insurance company
don't totally blame yourself a lot of
guys can't deal with their own [ __ ]
mortality or they live alone and who
gives a [ __ ] if they die right so policy
genius made it easy policy genius is the
easy easy way to compare life insurance
online in just five minutes you can
compare quotes from the top insurers to
find the best policy for you and will
you compare quotes you save money it's
that simple
in fact policy genius has helped over 4
million
people shop for insurance and placed
over twenty billion dollars in coverage
and they don't just make life insurance
easy they also compare disability
insurance renter's insurance health
insurance one-stop and sherrod stop here
if you care about it then they cover it
if you've been putting off life
insurance don't put it off any longer
it's never been easier to buy and rates
are at a 20-year low policy genius.com
the easy way to buy life compare and buy
life insurance I think I tell you one of
the best things I ever did was get life
insurance yeah oh yeah I have it too
it's like isn't it like a relief my
uncle works for farmers and he was like
dude you got to get it like let me hook
it up and it was super cheap yeah poor
easy yeah when you're young yeah I did
it when I was old like how old you
smoked cigars occasionally we'll give
you the old guy occasional fee yeah
you're supposed to say no no no but now
that they do they literally they [ __ ]
they take your blood now right I know
and they yeah you so you can lie all you
want they're gonna find out what you're
doing I say admit to more [ __ ] that you
doing so they don't take your blood and
figure out what you're actually doing or
they're like oh it's not that bad
considering all this other [ __ ] you've
been yeah whatever but I just like the
fact that when I die that everybody's
gonna be taken care of and it's not
gonna be like you know I've had buddies
of mine die you know unexpectedly you
know my age it's unexpected right this
your affairs are not in order and then
it's the double whammy yo where you know
it's the you're no longer there and then
people like how the [ __ ] are we gonna
live
yep how we gonna pay the rent and take
care and that's sad but you know what
isn't said is the joy of your new drum
video dude I'm so happy for you because
for the longest time I've been telling
you with your skills to utilize the
Internet
get out there especially because you got
something to say and all that and I am
thrilled for you and I hope this podcast
can help blow up the video because you
were the [ __ ] man
because I sucked at drums and I'm a
comedian I've actually had people come
up to me and say you know I've gotten to
the point where people come up to me and
be like that that wasn't that bad and
before yeah it was bad it was definitely
do that video were you at Dean's
birthday I was [ __ ] crushing oh my
god dude that was so much fun
yeah anybody yeah yeah I just might in
the [ __ ] out of everything that's what
it's all about man you know oh yeah that
was yeah I gotta be honest with you like
those those [ __ ] all of those things
when Cushing who hooked me up and I got
the jam yeah
couple of those guys know those my stuff
and slash I mean just like those things
are the biggest have anything I've ever
done in this business
those are the biggest those have been
the play [ __ ] Nikki Sixx yeah that's
incredible
yeah because I I really didn't earn it
that's what I guess I always feel like
with stand-up as much as you know doing
Letterman HBO special do [ __ ] like that
it's like I did the hell gigs like I
[ __ ] earned it and then Cracker
Barrel three in the morning and the
brass but there's DS Drummond gigs it's
not like I had to audition it's just
like oh that guy's funny I'll play a
song with them yeah I'm sick of the guys
in my band
get up there freckles see what you can
do
alright that's the Thursday afternoon
podcast very special guest Davie Lich
thank you so much for coming on finally
get you on and thank you for all the all
that all the help you've given me over
the years dude it's been yeah I've
learned so much myself dude and and one
more thing yeah I can't imagine you had
a [ __ ] student more difficult than me
oh I definitely believe not right right
I don't say but for everyone who's
listening to this if you want to go
check out the course you can go to my
website and during checkout if you type
in ber be URR you'll get 10% off off
everything get look at that that guy did
not embrace the internet now you [ __ ]
you're doing it better than I am I love
it all right that's the podcast enjoy
the music and then we'll have a little
throwback Thursday afternoon podcast
have a great weekend you [ __ ] and I'll
see you on Monday
[Music]
[Applause]
and Walker Zeldin
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's going on is Gilbert and it's
the Monday morning podcast from Monday
June 28th 2010 right off the bat you
should be thinking you know what bill
there's something weird with your voice
why does it sound like you're whispering
because I am [ __ ] whispering you
[ __ ] douchebag
why don't you go with your gut you know
didn't your [ __ ] brain just tell you
that I was whispering
did your parents beat you down mentally
that bad that you literally questioned
what that [ __ ] voice inside of you
was even saying that's the voice that
makes you [ __ ] when you go on a hike
and if that little voice in years going
is there a mountain lion staring at me
yes there is run all right I am
whispering because I'm doing this
[ __ ] thing at 8:20 in the morning my
girlfriend is sleeping in the other room
I taped this [ __ ] thing last night
but for some reason I screwed up and it
didn't record 50 minutes I [ __ ] did
it I was gonna upload it at midnight
just like last week okay and just like
last week I am once again douchebag of
the week back-to-back just like the
Lakers I'm a douchebag two years in a
[ __ ] row two weeks in a row I should
say two times in a row whatever you know
the analogy I'm trying to let you guys
know that I'm a [ __ ] idiot when it
comes to this the past two weeks and
kind of try and trash the Lakers anyways
but they don't give a [ __ ] they got
their rings right you know what a
wonderful organization they actually had
to switch their parade route because
they're stupid fans were rioting so much
a bunch of [ __ ] animals all right
Billy you ever gonna let the Lakers
Celtics series go you know what I don't
think I'm gonna I'm reminded of it
constantly like I started watching World
Cup soccer and watching all those
[ __ ] people flopping around on the
ground
anytime anybody kicked that back of
their socks reminded me of watching Pau
Gasol play basketball
[ __ ] flopping [ __ ] alright let's not
be this angry can't be angry and whisper
never seen that you see a couple
fighting public I do that angry
whispering that's not what he said you
know damn well what the [ __ ] is going on
oh shut the [ __ ] up
that's what I want to be doing so
anyways I actually did the podcast last
night already and fighting through I was
like sweating I was so goddamn sick I
did Vegas this weekend I performed at
the Orleans casino now if you stand up
nerds out there or fee fans of the
podcast who listen every week you know
that the Orleans casino was the last
place George Carlin did stand-up before
he died so I went there and I asked him
a ton of questions people who worked
there were totally cool even one of the
guys was actually telling me how Carlin
put together his hours of material you
know how he would come in and it would
be like an hour and 20 minutes and
before his special he'd watch him
whittle it down and by the end of the
weekend it would be like an hour right
on the nose gave me chills listening to
it and also made me really feel like I
need to start working harder as a
[ __ ] comedian and someone there also
gave me a ticket stub from his last show
was [ __ ] awesome but I made the
mistake I the only Orleans casino is
actually off the strip it's kind of cool
so my hotel room had a view of the
entire strip and I would have been
content to just stay out there at the
Orleans casino because I liked it I like
the vibe the crowd was a little bit
older as am i you know so there wasn't a
lot of craziness going on it was just
straight up let's booze let's eat let's
gamble you know I wasn't a bunch of
people [ __ ] you know you know like a
gaggle of chicks screaming out the
sunroof of a [ __ ] limo you know we
got a limo
[ __ ] you know you know I've really
tags everything with [ __ ] nowadays is
that from the Rick James sketch I'm Rick
James [ __ ] then everything became [ __ ]
or whatever long [ __ ] story you know
what I'm doing right now I'm looking at
my laptop and the screensaver just has
all all the albums on my itunes or all
the albums that don't really [ __ ]
exist the covers to the digital singles
that I downloaded I'm actually looking
at one that says Elvis
speaking of Las Vegas and I came out to
to Elvis the entire weekend I had to do
it I came out to that song that's used
to be cute and now I realize that it's
about stalking someone you know how's
that [ __ ] song go hide in the kitchen
had in the hall ain't gonna do you any
good at all goes one side something and
the kissing starts a team of wild horses
couldn't tear us apart it's like really
Elvis does does the woman have any say
in that I'm going to [ __ ] dawn Volvo
but uh yes stuck on you stuck on you you
would think that uh that would then
that's a guy in love but if you really
listen to the lyrics it isn't it's a guy
who can't accept the fact that the
relationship is over her mind and she
wants to move on and you know he just
won't [ __ ] leave her alone he keeps
pressing his sweaty out-of-shape iconic
stomach up against her as he kisses her
I mean that's what I got out of it but
it was a great song to come out to
nonetheless so anyways you probably
asking hey Bill you whisper in douche
how did you get sick I don't really know
but I know who I'm gonna blame it on how
about that I was [ __ ] like I said I
was content to stay off the strip at the
Orleans casino you know but I brought my
girlfriend so you know what that means
they want to do stuff let's go to this
strip I heard they had some stores they
have stores on the strip let's go to the
strip and go to the store so you want to
go to the stores on the strip huh
sweetie sweetie do you want to go to the
stores on the strip no of course I don't
why no I why would I want to do that I
had something I needed to buy I would go
but I don't I don't want to go you know
but I [ __ ] learned I've learned to
get through it a [ __ ] relationship
you got to say yes there's some [ __ ] you
don't want to [ __ ] do so I go yeah
yeah let's go to the [ __ ] stores on
the strip right so we [ __ ] go out
there and you know we go into all these
[ __ ] stores
I noticed those really high-end stores
when you go into them they they only
have like 40 pieces as they call them
you know it's very it's not like when
you go into Old Navy
hey what's waist size are you we got a
hundred of that you know we got a
hundred every [ __ ] size and they're
stacked from the floor up to the goddamn
ceiling and we got that ladder
that [ __ ] slides right across the
wall that's how much product we have in
here and that's just the goddamn
changing you know why cuz they're 30
bucks a whack but you go into those
[ __ ] high-end places and it stops
being jeans and dresses that starts
being called pieces
and all of a sudden there's like 28
things and there's a ton of space and
everybody in those stores looks like
Mike Myers and that [ __ ] sketchy used
to do you know where he danced around
like the [ __ ] German guy who liked to
get [ __ ] on sprocket or some [ __ ] I
don't care about what the [ __ ] name was
dressed all in black and he put his
hands on his hips and he only moved his
legs
can you guys hear that person there's
somebody giggling like a maniac
downstairs the person moved out
downstairs not the old guy my apartments
over two different apartments
it's a little [ __ ] spread out so
anyways we start going to those goddamn
shops long story short I can actually
admit one Louis Vuitton when you go in
there I really like their luggage man
and that luggage is [ __ ] insane like
it's handcrafted said I like that you
know
look at that handcrafted yeah some guy
took a hammer and nails on the inside
look at that craftsmanship you know they
have an old Louis Vuitton trunk from
like the early 1900s and it's still
functional you know why because it was
made by hand using great materials so I
was like you know and I like this [ __ ] I
like it wasn't made by a machine it was
made by a human being so I asked him the
smallest [ __ ] piece of luggage they
had which I guess would be considered
kind of like a jewelry box and I asked
him how much it was and they were like
$4,000 and I did the Eddie Murphy in
Beverly Hills Cop you know you know I
just totally played it off like I could
afford it
how's that guy that's great you know
okay now why don't you close up this
handcrafted thing and put it back up on
the [ __ ] shelf I was actually pissed
afterwards
four grand they [ __ ] look me right in
the eye when they said four grand for
great you look at the [ __ ] floor when
you throw a goddamn number out like that
should be ashamed of yourself charging
that much [ __ ] money I don't
understand
do you know [ __ ] rich you'd have to
be to buy a $4,000 [ __ ] jewelry box
Jesus Christ most people their jewelry
isn't worth that much and then where the
[ __ ] do you take it that's the thing
about buying really nice clothes and
really nice stuff I got my legs crossed
right now and I'm swinging my foot
around the [ __ ] is wrong with me just
got myself in a really effeminate moment
whatever I'm allowed Arnie what the [ __ ]
you gonna do like someone will like
that's when you know you're rich when
someone will mug you not for what's in
your luggage they'll just
you for your [ __ ] luggage you know
when I go to do uh the David Letterman
program I always go out I buy a nice
goddamn suit I always lose money
whenever I do that show but I'm not
going out there looking like a bum and I
love the suits and I love wearing them
but the second you put them on
you're freaking out like oh my god
uh-huh anything you go to brush up
against you freak out because it's an
expensive goddamn suit as opposed to
when you shop at Old Navy in the gap
you know the anti [ __ ] wear that they
sell I wouldn't give a [ __ ] if I was
walking through a [ __ ] pigsty I mean
I freaked oh my god pig [ __ ] oh it's
okay I'm wearing gap jeans
I've never wore gap jeans I would never
do that do you know there was a kid in
my high school his nickname was the Gap
nerd anyd he had no idea people he's no
one said to his face cuz he was a bigger
guy but he always wore gap jeans and he
wasn't even that big of a nerd not he
always tucked his shirts in because it
was the 80s and yeah they called him the
Gap nerd and that was the end of his
[ __ ] getting career you had no idea I
had no idea you had to do with this big
six-foot four inch [ __ ] red corduroy
Gap jeans big stupid tag on the back Gap
it's like don't you notice that
everybody else's says Levi Strauss
that's what you want to have on and then
the couple of kids whose dads have
mafioso connections there's actually
actually have guest jeans you know which
in my world was chick jeans back then
anyways I'm getting off the [ __ ]
beaten track so anyway so we were going
through all these these high-end [ __ ]
stores I went into the Tom Ford store
some of the most beautiful suits have
ever seen in my life also some of the
most expensive but you get caught up in
it
I was actually in there because Tom Ford
his entire line is not just a line it's
like a lifestyle and it's like that dull
sekiz beer guy stay thirsty my friends
it's like Steve McQueen man's man
they had a [ __ ] run a cigar cutter
cutter made out of like a [ __ ] I was
gonna say a rhino horn it wasn't it was
an ox horn an ox horn cigar cutter
one of the most manliest [ __ ] things
I've ever seen and I'm actually thinking
about buying it I'm holding this [ __ ]
ox horn you know they had a ram horn
cigarette lighter I'm not even lying
joking I'm actually considering buying
this [ __ ] thing fortunately I walked
out of this store you know and like ten
minutes went by and then I just kind of
had like that little [ __ ] gut check
moment there or whatever kind of looking
at myself like dude did you almost just
buy a [ __ ] oxhorn cigar cutter
did you really almost do did you did you
get that [ __ ] caught up and that bull
[ __ ] is like yeah I did a couple of
things kept snapping me back into
reality I don't like my I don't like
buying [ __ ] made out of animals unless
it's a leather jacket it's just a stupid
cow ate hamburgers anyways it'd be
[ __ ] hypocritical wouldn't it [ __ ]
cows already dead why don't we go the
Native American route and use up this
whole [ __ ] cow you know but I don't
eat ox although I did go to a Mario
Batali restaurant one time and I got an
oxtail [ __ ] stew or something I can't
even know what the fella was but it was
delicious but anyways just no [ __ ]
need unless the ox was already dead any
like well we might as well soft its
[ __ ] horns and turned it into a cigar
cutter anyway so we get out of that
thing
and speaking of [ __ ] cows so I don't
know my girls like let's go get
something to eat and I said alright
there's a [ __ ] McDonald's right
there and she's like do you want to eat
there and soda was looking down at the
ground all sad you know just doing that
classic female manipulation thing she
knew I wanted to eat there I just said
there's a McDonald's there and then why
would she say do you want to eat there
and look down at the ground this
question is for all the young male
listeners of my whispering podcast why
would a female do that do-do-do-do-do
I'll tell you why because she doesn't
want if not only does she not want to
[ __ ] eat there
she already has a place where she wants
to eat she's art she's already had this
place that she's wanted wanted to eat it
for probably a month before you ever
went to Vegas but she's not gonna tell
you about it because if she told you
about it that give you time to do
research on it and find out how [ __ ]
expensive it was so she's like do you
wanna eat that she looks down at the
ground so immediately despite the fact
that I know all this about females I
take the bait why where do you want to
eat sweetheart and there's this burger
place at Mandalay Bay I heard it was
really nice do you ever watch Top Chef
only when you're watching it sweetheart
I don't like that show [ __ ] show is
annoying
I hate when the chef starts screaming at
those people [ __ ] foreign accent you
called that a [ __ ] grilled cheese
sandwich get the [ __ ] out of my kitchen
hey hey you think I'm [ __ ] afraid of
you you [ __ ] douche you got a [ __ ]
problem with my grilled cheese sandwich
you come up like a [ __ ] gentleman and
you take me aside don't [ __ ] be
screaming at me when I got these [ __ ]
knives in my hand stick it right through
your goddamn trachea what do you think
about that huh I'll give you a [ __ ]
blow hole right out the front of your
[ __ ] neck get out of my goddamn face
before I take you up by your [ __ ]
hair and mush your face into this pile
of shrimp huh that I haven't taken the
shells off so I'll give you a bunch of
little razor cuts
sorry could you actually smother
somebody that you know I used to work in
a restaurant where I worked the mesquite
grill I worked in a fancy restaurant
called the sable cafe in Cary North
Carolina very short-lived it was
supposed to be five-star dining yet they
had me working on a mesquite grill
glassed-in
with a big chef's hat as all these
[ __ ] people will be looking at me you
know I had to cook up all the [ __ ] and I
was done you know burgers front
brochettes the chicken sandwiches
whatever the [ __ ] we will make in the
swordfish specials and then I turn
around there was a little window and I'd
handed to the [ __ ] Metallica fan who
I worked with who had to stick his hair
up in the hat with his prepubescent
[ __ ] mustache even though he was 19
that was a funny thing about that job is
I'd be sitting there looking out at all
these quote-unquote
elegant people and Cary North Carolina
and then I'd look through the little
porthole where I would stick the food
through to give to the [ __ ] drug
addicts on the line I remember who they
had a guy back there who was on a work
release program like at night he was in
jail but at during the day he cooked at
this [ __ ] restaurant this guy was a
douchebag
and one time we what we were on our way
to going out of business so at one time
I was literally the grill chef the
busboy
and the dishwasher let's not even get
involved in the amount of [ __ ] health
code violations that they were involved
in there because I would I did not have
time to wash my [ __ ] hands and put it
that way um so one day we was slammed
and I went back going hey we need some
more glasses you know because we were
running low on glasses and the [ __ ]
douche on the work release program goes
well why don't we wash some ah a novel
idea you know like he's [ __ ]
intelligent or something ah a novel idea
it was only because the guy was was in
[ __ ] prison
that I didn't say anything to him he had
that so
credibility but looking back he was a
[ __ ] [ __ ] goddamn little [ __ ] he
wasn't even that tall and this is back
in the day though when you weren't that
tall and if you weren't that tall you
weren't that tough you were tough for a
little guy but you're still a little guy
this is before jiu-jitsu had made it to
America there was no UFC you know
remember the first [ __ ] UFC and hoist
Gracie kept fighting all those big guys
and you think that he was about ready to
get punched in the chest and the [ __ ]
face or whatever and then all of a
sudden he grabbed their little finger
and bend it back and whatever the [ __ ]
he was do you didn't know what he was
doing was like magic he was like ah that
little guy's gonna get the [ __ ] kicked
out of him then the other guy be like
I'm right all right all right all right
all right
so yeah the men hilarious
there's nothing worse than taking [ __ ]
from somebody and you don't give them
[ __ ] back we can you know why because 23
[ __ ] laterz years later it's still
bugs you you guys hey there's a good
there's a great one if you guys want you
want to you want to uh the [ __ ] is the
word I'm trying to say if you want to
participate in the podcast what's the
law I want to find out what the longest
like who the oldest person is on my
podcast what's the longest you've held
on to some [ __ ] all right there's one
that was from 1987-88 at least 22
[ __ ] years ago it still bugs me every
once in a while just pop in my head well
why don't we wash some glasses ah a
novel idea hey why don't we not live on
life a [ __ ] crime so we don't have to
go to jail you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
you know the [ __ ] did you do to get in
jail you dumb [ __ ] idiot you douche I
bet you one of those guys who pulled his
shirt over his [ __ ] head and tried to
rob a 7-eleven on a whim there was
another thing before they had really
good security cameras oh this [ __ ]
wasn't on America's dumbest criminals I
really [ __ ] hate that guy still to
this day I remember I had a math teacher
one time and he goes he was asking
questions and he goes for number seven
let's call on the dumbest kid in the
room bill burr and it still [ __ ] bugs
me
that was like [ __ ] 24 years ago you
know what I think that that's what
heaven is to me when I die I go to
heaven and then there's just a line of
[ __ ] people that gave me [ __ ]
throughout my life and I never punched
him in the face and they just come one
at a time and I blast him in then they
say what they said to me then and I
blast them in the face and it doesn't
even hurt my hand cuz it's heaven you
know and I always [ __ ] win
Wow it's a lot of anger isn't it okay
let's plow ahead so I go all right
sweetie let's [ __ ] go up to the
goddamn Mandalay Bay I've never been
there so anyways like I said it was it's
run by one of the winners of Hell's
Kitchen or some [ __ ] and when the
reality is is what I'm not realizing is
people who win that show I'm now really
starting to believe like it's like Last
Comic Standing you go to go to the
winner of Last Comic Standing oh this
guy won Last Comic Standing and then
you're going to go see some open mic
arzga ten [ __ ] minutes of material
I'm basing that on the first season I
don't know who won the other [ __ ]
seasons but it's a reality show so I
imagine it's it's a [ __ ] I don't know
somebody with like a [ __ ] hula hoop
going around their head somebody with
some sort of hook God knows that's how
this business works you got to have a
hook you know if anything told me that
it was looking at the people headlining
in Las Vegas
yeah that's not true there's actually
some real comedians out there George
Wallace I know Bobby Slayton worked out
there for a while there was real comics
out there but the guys who make the big
[ __ ] bucks
they just do [ __ ] but you know puppets
how the [ __ ] is that still entertaining
and 2010 you know like what I can't do
Philip wisdom is that right
ventriloquism is that the right word you
wanna hear me talk without moving my
[ __ ] lips I can do that [ __ ] hey
there they are dummy what did you do
today yeah [ __ ] you bill you're dumber
than I am isn't that funny
huh the dummy saying you're [ __ ] dumb
no wait I gotta have a stupid voice
right take it to another level
Hulu Google dude [ __ ] it sold-out
shows at Caesars 10 million a year
Entertainer of the Year bill burr and
[ __ ] ham face [ __ ] your [ __ ]
puppet is why is the [ __ ] puppet
always smarter can't somebody switch
that up
I'd be arguing with my puppet the second
the puppet started giving me [ __ ] oh
really you're so [ __ ] smart
what if I take my hand out of your back
now look at you he just fell on your
wooden face didn't you you dumb [ __ ]
then I turn on the crowd what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you people
what is it the 1930s won't we what do
you want me to do after that she was
what's my [ __ ] on car come out here
and do the goddamn Charleston Charleston
I could even say it
all right 25 whispering minutes in I'm
actually starting to get a louder but
you know what the Sun is a little higher
in the sky you like that did I sound
like a Native American anyways so what
Jesus Christ let's get to the [ __ ]
Mandalay Bay so we go over to the
Mandalay Bay and oh yeah that's what I'm
realizing that I'm eating at an open mic
Herz [ __ ] restaurant I didn't even
realize that until afterwards I eat the
burger I got one of their Kobe beef
burgers all right now let me say
something positive about Mandalay Bay
before I get out of that they had some
[ __ ] insane shows coming up at their
house of Blues
alright Joe Rogan friend of this podcast
and he had me on his podcast last week
Joe Rogan is going to be performing
there on July 3rd at Mandalay Bay at the
House of Blues the day before the the
big UFC fight UFC
sharp your trip of the wound you ever
see that Joe Rogan video the buffer 360
you got to see that just a [ __ ]
search that there's a [ __ ] I don't
know if it's a YouTube video or if it's
just on his website Joe Rogan dotnet but
check that one out really [ __ ] funny
video
but anyways he's playing there and Lamb
of God if you were into that a tolerable
sort of death metal that guy still sings
in that [ __ ] you know Tom Waits voice
Tom Waits is really the father of death
metal if you listen to it the way that
guy sinks on a doubt I agree you know or
maybe Louis Armstrong I think it goes
Louis Armstrong Tom Waits and then
[ __ ] death metal now I see trees of
green
anyways so that's a good [ __ ] at
Mandalay Bay the bad [ __ ] as we go to
this [ __ ] burger place I can't
remember the name of him we go in there
and I order a sixteen dollar and fifty
cent [ __ ] Kobe beef burger and
they're talking about how it's the
greatest goddamn burger oh you know the
highest quality [ __ ] meat yadda
[ __ ] yadda my girl orders one to 1650
and 1650 what is that kids that's 33
bucks plus fries Plus drinks all that
[ __ ] you know the mob doesn't run
Vegas anymore you can't go out and get
yourself a $2 steak the whole [ __ ]
place out there now is a goddamn it's a
[ __ ] over
so whatever cost me like 40-something
bucks 50 bucks with the goddamn tip I
eat it you know what wasn't even that
good my girls like how's your burger you
know what I said I said it's good just
keeping the peace keeping the water nice
and smooth nice and [ __ ] still on the
horizon okay so anyways I get back to my
hotel my girl already tells me she
doesn't feel too good that that burgers
sitting in her like a goddamn
and I'm like you know what I feel fine I
get ready to do my show iron my
button-down shirt put a little
conditioner in my hair what's left of it
shape it up a little and I head
downstairs to go work the Orleans casino
the last place Carla never worked the
place where The Smothers Brothers
retired you know
Smothers Brothers who were so [ __ ]
edgy they actually lost their sketch
show during the Vietnam War they did so
I forget what the sketch was but they
had the balls to say no to the network
and do a sketch that was actually
criticizing what the [ __ ] we were doing
over there and they lost that goddamn
show you know I don't know about you
guys but for me that's lifetime respect
so anyways I walked down there and I'm
going through the Orleans casino and
then all of a sudden it just [ __ ]
hits me boom right my stomach like some
capsule some time release CIA you're
gonna [ __ ] your pants [ __ ] capsule
goes off and I know there is no question
that whatever I just ate was not good
for my body and it was about to reject
it one way or the other without getting
crude people when something goes into
your stomach if it's coming out it only
has two options alright anyways I just
thought of a really really bad joke for
the [ __ ] third one and I'm not gonna
say it but it involved stabbing yourself
in the stomach and you can fill in the
blanks on that one alright so anyways so
he gotta be [ __ ] do you got to be
[ __ ] me no pun intended so I go in
the back way the same way that Karlin
used to go in because I've already asked
everybody every [ __ ] question litter
there's so much I'm into Karlin how did
he leave did he hang out no he'd say
goodnight he would go right out the door
and he'd be in the car and he wasn't
difficult to work with I guess he had
arthritis at the end of his life and
the sound guy was saying one show he
forgot to take the bottle caps off the
water bottles and he saw that Carlin was
struggling with them and when he got off
because George I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
and George just like whacked Matt out
come on come on I don't give a [ __ ]
don't worry he just walked out I guess
he was a really great guy
so anyways I'm walking through this
legendary door and you know and what's
worse is like I know what's going to
happen but I know it's not gonna happen
for like another 15 minutes and
coincidentally the [ __ ] show starts
in 15 minutes and I'm going on first
alright and this guy when you're
backstage literally says 20 minutes till
Showtime 20 minutes till Showtime he
like counts it down I never get nervous
before shows but this guy counting down
the show is making me nervous
15 minutes till Showtime okay and it's
starting to get worse and [ __ ] it get
literally gets down to two minutes
before showtime and I'm questioning can
I make it through a half-hour set and I
was like you know what [ __ ] this the
show can't start without me my opening
music is Elvis Presley anyways the [ __ ]
do I care they can listen to that song
I'm going to Roma fingers loose your
long black hair slam your [ __ ] face
off the [ __ ] sink
oh-ho I don't give a [ __ ] and I said
[ __ ] it and I [ __ ] ran into the
bathroom and I will spare you the
details but you know when something
either amazing or something amazing
happens they make a statue if something
horrific happens a lot of times they
will preserve the area you know like
Dealey Plaza [ __ ] president gets his
brains blown out all of a sudden we
can't change one blade of [ __ ] grass
the horror that happened in that [ __ ]
bathroom ladies and gentlemen I never do
[ __ ] jokes they should have retired that
[ __ ] bathroom that's it they should
have just [ __ ] air-sealed it and just
put
glass [ __ ] door so people could look
in and realize why they closed that
[ __ ] burger joint at the Mandalay Bay
and I got a mint dude I have I haven't
this is it's Monday I'm finally back to
normal so there you go there's my big
[ __ ] story I had a burger over at the
[ __ ] Mandalay Bay and it almost
ruined my [ __ ] show over at the
Orleans so if you guys saw me anybody
saw me Saturday night alright you want
to talk about a professional because I
extra [ __ ] killed on that show if you
knew what the [ __ ] happened just know
that the next time you go to Vegas and
you go to see Barry Manilow and he's
singing that song Mandy you something
you some and then you some dead but I
still want to [ __ ] you Oh Mandy right
just know that he could have just been
[ __ ] his [ __ ] brains out two
minutes before he put on his rayon
[ __ ] slacks with his horrific plastic
surgery his yank back face I bet you
know I was gonna say he'd be in another
facelift if he [ __ ] [ __ ] the way I did
before my show but that's actually not
true there's no strain there was no
straining anyways all right bill Jesus
Christ enough already
so anyways one of the things I like to
do when I go out to Vegas is I like to
check out some of the acts that are out
there because Las Vegas is a viable
option for a stand-up comedian if things
aren't going well for you in in
Hollywood but you're a huge draw if you
can actually go out there like you know
some of the comedians that are out there
won't name names but they're making a
ridiculous amount of money you know 3
million 4 5 7 million dollar contracts
for the year and you don't have to
travel you don't have to go on the road
or nothing and believe me I have thought
about it
I've thought about it it's like you
[ __ ] kidding me four million I'd stay
out there for a year I just do it I'd
get a [ __ ] I think I already talked
about this I'd have a a this is how I
had a plan I was gonna have a [ __ ] a
really [ __ ] slamming house that I
would rent and then I would make the
casino give me a car service and I would
just have him pick me up drive me to the
gig walk right in the back door like
Carlin do my show and walk that's
probably why I did it I [ __ ] walk
right back out get me in the car and I
get the [ __ ] out of there you know that
way I wouldn't get sick of the casinos
or any of that type of [ __ ] or at least
it would take longer but someone was
telling me that Celine Dion actually has
it down and yes I am comparing myself to
Celine Dion because sometimes I don't
know if you guys notice when I'm really
feeling a joke I start punching myself
in the chest her [ __ ] music is
horrific
she's like the white version of Beyonce
you know where she's really successful
I'd actually [ __ ] her but the sound of
her voice makes me want to just [ __ ]
kill myself you know I mean how hot is
Beyonce but her voice is [ __ ] it's
beyond horrific it's like it's
unacceptable doesn't she sound like
she's singing like two octaves higher
than she should be the worst is when
you're in like a restaurant and they
just have it on it's sort of low volume
in the background and you're like is
someone choking on their food actually
that wouldn't make sense because that
would mean that you could actually get
air out there's somebody sort of choking
on their food is there a an SM couple in
the corner booth and the dude is
applying just enough pressure all right
anyway she had it down the best Celine
Dion like she would let a helicopter
pick her up at her [ __ ] house she'd
land on top of the casino you guys don't
Stan how much of a dream this is any
performer who's listening to this is
[ __ ] it's got a [ __ ] hard-on at
this point this is the ultimate alright
other than just having a [ __ ] evil
twin robot who always kills and just
goes out and does your shows you know
and the [ __ ] helicopter would pick
her up at the house flyer over to the
casino land on top of the casino and
then she would just go down go out sing
punch herself in the chest and then just
[ __ ] get back on the helicopter and
ride back do you realize that means she
was doing her vocal warm up in like her
bathroom you know and like five seconds
later or whatever as she sat in her
kitchen eating [ __ ] fruit loops or
some [ __ ] you know then you hear the
[ __ ] sound of those helicopter blades
I'll do it I would be listening to theme
from mash you know maybe some of that
music that they listen to and like
Apocalypse Now was some of the music
that they listened to was that the one
at one of those war movies where they
would listen to the doors this is the
end do do do my Olli
Freddy and you probably wonder why Bill
what the [ __ ] are you singing so much
for on your podcast this week I'll tell
you why because I went out to Vegas and
I saw a group out there that was selling
out and it was frustrating to me how
much people like singers this group had
the worst [ __ ] name of any group I've
ever seen in my life
alright it was four people three guys in
one girl all with like the [ __ ]
facelifts face yanked back the [ __ ]
hair dyed all well into their 50s except
for one of them who might have been 38
and I thought they were an acapella
group they're not they sing and they
have a band there and the name of the
group was vocal soup
vocals soup is that not the most
disgusting [ __ ] name you've ever
[ __ ] heard who came up with that
vocal soup so I'm like I have to go I
have to go on YouTube look them up look
up vocal soup and click on vocal soup in
concert and I'm gonna sing you some of
their lyrics they sing vocal soup yeah
yeah you take four cool voices and
you're make them hot and you give it
everything you got you get vocal soup
how [ __ ] gross is that it just makes
you gag just to think of it and then the
[ __ ] lyrics they they do nothing to
try to make it less gross there's
actually a line in that then they're
stupid theme song that you won't stop
slurping till you're burping up vocal
soup and the end of the video I [ __ ] you
not speaking of [ __ ] which is the
reoccurring theme of this podcast they
actually have an animated bowl of soup
that a [ __ ] Brown it looks like a bowl
of [ __ ] diarrhea I know it's gross
but I have to accurately describe it and
they have notes coming out of it with
the steam vocal soup
it's [ __ ] horrific vocal soup and
this is what killed me is the one guy in
the band the rocker is actually this guy
from the group foreigner and it's just
like okay whatever you know I don't know
if foreigners broke up right now and you
had a bad deal some behind the music
[ __ ] you need money eh I respect it but
how the [ __ ] did you sign off on vocal
soup former person that was in foreigner
you know you know you didn't speak up
like hey guys you know I don't want a
big league anybody
you know but I I wasn't a band that not
not only sold-out arenas not only had a
number-one record but I wanted to say we
actually had a pretty cool [ __ ] name
I think we can do better than vocal soup
I mean I don't want to go the hacky
route here with like what movie other
rope shoots
what were the other options throat puke
[ __ ] throat puke yeah yeah
you won't stop yakking till you [ __ ]
burping up stomach acid
it's [ __ ] horrific but of course they
sell out they sell out and everybody
loves him and I guess the piano player
worked with Frank Sinatra for 10 [ __ ]
years and he also signed off on vocal
soup it's just I don't know but they
sell out you know that's what the [ __ ]
happens in Vegas and it really you know
Vegas will really help you understand
this business as a performer like why
good things don't make it and why [ __ ]
makes it you got to do is [ __ ] go out
there you know put a [ __ ] toilet seat
on your head
toilet seat head yeah again if you don't
have a toilet in you want to take a [ __ ]
and [ __ ] um all right I think that's it
I'm running out of [ __ ] steam here
let's recommend some YouTube videos here
YouTube video I already told you to
check out vocal soup oh it's just making
me sick to my stomach to continue to say
that name YouTube video look up best cry
ever it's unbelievable and then of
course you got to hit the auto-tune
remix of it it really is the best one
ever but don't look at the popeyes
chicken one I hate when they people do
those that racist [ __ ] you know anyways
and then there's another one this is
just an uncomfortable podcast I talk to
you about my bodily functions
I brought up vocal soup and just for the
trifecta of disgusting it's usually not
it's never been this disgusting this
this I'm gonna nominate this one for the
most disgusting podcast of all time and
this is the cherry on top here the last
YouTube video is chimp
rapes frog it's really [ __ ] I
actually had to shut it off I had to
shut it off
it started off it's sort of funny and
then it's bizarre and then the people in
the background who are filming it are so
[ __ ] dumb that you can't I don't know
they just listen to them and you hear
that their parents and you know you
realize why we shouldn't have tried to
stop the swine flu swine flu I can't
even talk sorry I'm trying to talk and
type at the same time and here's
something new here's here's the [ __ ]
cool old car of the week go on go on
YouTube and look up a Nash metropolitan
now I'm sure people made fun of this and
you're gonna be like of course you like
this car bill because you drive a
[ __ ] Prius but you got to check this
this car was a [ __ ] badass car when
they were making all these huge cars
back in the day they made this little
[ __ ] car I don't know check it out
tell me what you think about it some
people like redid theirs I know it's not
a [ __ ] McLaren don't be a [ __ ] just
check it out it's a cool [ __ ] car by
international I guess Nash and
international is somehow combined or
something I want to happen they became
American Motors I really should have
looked that part up that's a [ __ ]
cool car it's got three on the tree you
know you know the old-school cars we had
like the you know the if it was an
automatic the park neutral reverse drive
all that [ __ ] was right on the steering
column I think the last time they made a
car with if it was a it was a standard
and you shifted up there they called it
three on the tree and I'd never even
heard of that until I was like [ __ ]
two
five years old because those cars were
long gone but this thing three on the
[ __ ] tree check it out a Nash
metropolitan and you know what that's
gonna be it for the whispering podcast
this week and maybe it was a good thing
that I whispered it cuz it was so
[ __ ] disgusting let me let me hype
some of my gigs coming up here let me go
to the official website of Bill burr I'm
gonna be the next gig I have I'm not
working again until I actually have July
12th on my website but I have to change
that I don't get to Montreal till the
13th people
July 13th through the 17th I'm gonna be
in Montreal Canada
speaking of cities that riot after they
win or lose just like Los Angeles
another sports town of [ __ ] animals
who attacked police officers and tip
over cars even if they [ __ ] win win
or lose I'm gonna be up at the Montreal
Comedy Festival the Just for Laughs
festival doing my new one hour of
material so while you [ __ ] frogs up
there and want to pretend like you're
from Paris speaking of that [ __ ]
I love the I'm actually gonna burn a job
burn a joke how many [ __ ] listeners
do I have actually you know what my the
guy who actually set up my entire
podcast player told me a week ago that
as of the beginning of this month told
me this a week ago I had 1 million three
thousand something downloads of my
podcast do you want if you [ __ ]
understand that for a second let's think
about that for a second if I charged a
dollar a podcast I wouldn't have to do
this [ __ ] podcast anymore that's
actually [ __ ] first of all people
wouldn't have you know I know a lot of
people go back and they download all 150
and if it was a buck apiece they
wouldn't but if I charged a dime apiece
I would had a hundred grand 100 [ __ ]
grand you know
it's almost as much as vocal soup makes
a knight alright so anyways maybe I'll
do that maybe I'll charge like a [ __ ]
dime because if he didn't notice from
the from the story I was telling you
about working Vegas and not having to do
the road and that type of thing that's
what happens to performers after a while
is it's not the doing of the show it's
the [ __ ] travel and you try to figure
out how the [ __ ] I can get off the road
initially the road seems like a cool fun
thing to do when it is but then as you
get older and you've been pretty much
everywhere you try to look for ways what
would you guys do if I charge $0.10 now
what would that be
$0.10 you guys are really gonna expose
me for how dumb I am that means you can
download the entire podcast for 53
[ __ ] years for 15 bucks you know be
$15 I'd have a hundred grand in my
pocket granted it would go down to like
[ __ ] 50 after the goddamn government
came in but you know what you know what
that would do that would buy me a new
[ __ ] Dodge Challenger the [ __ ]
top-of-the-line one with the [ __ ]
stripe on it and [ __ ] don't worry I'm
not I'm not gonna charge a dime but what
I am gonna do is I'm gonna start I'm at
the beginning of guilting you guys into
buying my new DVD okay just for the
simple fact that I don't charge for this
[ __ ] I am real I'm gonna let you
guys know that I'm gonna guilt you
[ __ ] alright pay it forward and
it's not you can't just buy one of my
DVDs you gotta buy two one for yourself
to show all your friends and then you
got to buy this second one for somebody
that you don't really like but you have
to buy him a gift it's a great [ __ ]
gift you know your boss you have Conti
[ __ ] sister-in-law you know and you
have to get him a gift cuz they're
getting you a gift is that's a great
gift to get is my [ __ ] DVD it's only
[ __ ] 20 bucks
there you go you can't shut your face
and watch this guy trash women for an
hour that's it everybody that's the
podcast for this week I apologize that
it was so [ __ ] graphic I usually
don't tell [ __ ] stories [ __ ] jokes
bodily feel fluid stories but it
happened what do you want from me but
anyways I want to thank the Orleans
casino for having me
I had a [ __ ] great time if you go out
to Vegas go to the Orleans and casino
you know if you a little more mature and
you don't want to deal with those
[ __ ] [ __ ] walking around oh hey I
got I got to give you guys the name of
this [ __ ] thing actually I'm not one
of these guys who's into art really bill
you just did a [ __ ] [ __ ] joke for
[ __ ] 45 minutes if you guys next time
you go out to Vegas go out to the Peter
lik gallery Peter lik Li K this guy
takes pictures of like beautiful scenes
in nature and he uses this camera from
like the 1930s that it literally takes a
minute for the camera to take a picture
and obviously I don't know [ __ ] about
photography but I don't know what he
does he opened something it's wide open
and he hits it and because it takes so
long to take the picture it gets all
these unbelievable colors it literally
looks like an HD TV picture and they
stick you in these rooms and with these
dimmers and what they do is they dim the
lights down you you it looks like the
Sun is going to I can't explain it but
they're they have a gallery in Mandalay
Bay the Venetian and the that mall that
covered mall there yeah Caesars Palace
definitely check that out if you're
going out to Vegas Peter lik you know
when you're done checking out Joe Rogan
at the House of Blues July 3rd go to the
oh you could do that go up there don't
get a hamburger
check out the Peter lik pictures and
have them sit you down in one of the in
one of the rooms and have them dim the
[ __ ] lights and check it out man
Peter lik man it's the [ __ ]
all right that's it I hope it was funny
I hope it was a funny podcast I felt a
little [ __ ] hampered by the fact I
had the whisper here but uh what the
hell did I do did I just shut this
[ __ ] thing off no I didn't all right
you guys everybody have a good week
[Music]
[Applause]
and water filter
[Music]
water
[Applause]
[Music]
aha
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]